good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy thursday hope
everyone's having an amazing blessed
and just safe and wonderful day happy
thursday everyone you guys were
so close to friday it's a beautiful
feeling
i'm so excited you have only one more
waking up to do before you can stay
asleep before you can live the alarm
free life yeah that's i live five days
for two to live the alarm free life
no and it's like i work hard so that
one day i won't have to ever set an
alarm again unless i have a flight to
catch you know
no i work hard sleep harder so hard i
sleep so hard like
sometimes a nuclear bomb could go off
and like it wouldn't even startle me
like i'm just
too dead asleep so i've actually it's
interesting that you bring this up
because um i was thinking about whether
i was gonna share you know my personal
anecdote of the day
but my pod i've been having disrupted
sleeps
p-a-o-d-p-a-o-d and
you know how i've been complaining a lot
recently that my legs hurt
yes like every this is something that
you
sometimes happens to me infrequently but
recently it's been happening a lot where
my legs just like
hurt and the only way to describe like
the pain is like they just feel so
weary yeah not a cramp like it's not a
throb like
they just ache of weariness and so
yesterday i decided to you know do some
google diagnosing
of course and it turns the safest thing
you could do it turns out what i have
is restless leg syndrome excuse me i've
been saying for
years that i have restless legs it's
literally what i have because
one of the symptoms is pain in the legs
mostly happens during the evenings
and the biggest thing is that you have
like an you can't control
moving your legs all the time and when
zach and i go to bed
and i'm always moving around he
literally has to tell me to stop moving
and it's my but now
it's my rls like you have rdh i have rls
no but by the way
and it also makes you tired during the
day which would explain why i'm never
quite awake and it just explains
all of my life's qualms it doesn't
explain the migraines though that would
be nice if it just all wrapped up
i have had this leg problem since i was
a child and me too never forget when i
was a kid and i saw a commercial for
restless leg syndrome and they were
literally describing what i was feeling
i never got like meds or anything i just
diagnosed myself on the spot i do have
restless
syndrome i did go to a doctor and they
thought it was a potassium deficiency
which it's not it's restless leg
syndrome
it is the [ __ ] worst yeah i know it's
the worst
when i was younger it used to only be in
the back of my knees and it would be
when i stayed up a little too late and
like that's how i knew it was time to go
to sleep
but now like last night i had it in my
hips and i was like okay i'm taking to
google
google also says that like it's not
something that's really treatable and
something that you just live with and i
mean it's like not the craziest feeling
in the world it just feels so strange
but also google said that it flares up
after like long periods of sitting like
in a car ride that's why when we came
when we went to newport night i was
complaining so much because we had been
in the car for four hours and
also like well that explains why i have
the disease
i'm constantly sitting true so like i'm
just
learning stuff about myself and i feel
like that's why i'm always crossing and
uncrossing my legs
on the show i just have rls so if you
see it me acting up
just know like i just feel like millions
of americans suffer from rls
every year and we're just like the quiet
we're like just quietly we're suffering
in silence
because it's not because it's not that
serious right it's just like an
interesting thing that happens
and it's people don't take you seriously
because when it's like oh my legs you're
not saying like oh my legs hurt because
it's not really pain it's just like on
discomfort it's yeah no you're right
last night it was like
really uncomfortable that i actually
took a bath
oh wow which is not something that i
typically do by the way i find that
taking advil helps
yeah i'm sure i'm sure that it might i
don't know advil i feel like doesn't
work
well i feel like half the time it not
even like my house
is literally like runs on advil if we
are out of advil
it is or tums it is pandemonium like
we cannot survive one minute without
advil or tums you remember
the beginning of covid you know it was
said that you shouldn't take
ibuprofen because it will exasperate
your symptoms so like i really stuck to
that and then it wasn't until yom kippur
ben offered me an advil when i got like
my fasting migraine
and it hadn't occurred to me for eight
months that i could take advil
well the thing with advil is the more
you take it the less it works so you
actually taking eight months off of
advil like might have been an amazing
thing for you
spoiler alert still didn't work still
had to take my magical pill
i love advil like there is not a problem
that advil can't fix you know yeah i
wish i had that experience
except for migraines yeah that's the one
thing advil can't tackle but like
literally broken leg but like advil
physical pain okay i'll try it next time
my rls flares up
no i'm so glad we spoke about this like
i i've been saying
for years and nobody takes you seriously
no nobody takes you seriously do you
think it's hereditary
well i did see i'm remembering now in my
google diagnosis it did say that it can
be genetic
so it would make sense that you and i
both have it yes it's the worst imagine
like theo has it too and he's just like
suffering in silence oh my god and
that's why he's always so sleepy and
that's why he's always going like this
can i get a wide shot
this is what he does in his sleep
no that is him being so imaginative and
having crazy dreams of him
running through fields and frolicking in
the gardens it was the rls acting up so
so we've got we've got a fabulous show
for you guys today
we are of course recapping everything
that went on in pop culture yesterday
we are also recapping a little tv
because the real housewives of orange
county was on last night and jackie and
i both watched i watched
two and a half you watched one episode
of the david letterman show i'm spacing
them adam um
well it's like i'm so excited about the
idea of them and so far i only watched
kim and maybe we'll just get into our
recap right now even though i want to
save it for the tv recap i just want to
like
preface my tv recap by just one
statement i
hate david letterman okay i was
literally just having this conversation
i absolutely like and i feel like i'm
about to offend
so many people but i guess that's what
we do here these days
um i i know what it is about
let's just wait for the tv wait for the
tv recap because i just have so like but
david letterman stands
be warned i you know what i really don't
think there's that many david letter in
the venn diagram of david letterman
and toast fans like i don't think
there's that many people in the middle
yeah who like
are going care enough to be offended
okay good i i absolutely love to hear
that um
and i also i watched the cmt awards last
night surprised yes you did i would love
to hear
the experience and it's just you know
country music when it comes to remote
award shows
is far superior to other genres and the
cmt awards was
nothing short of spectacular i thought
they did a great job i loved all three
co-hosts sarah highland
ashley mcbride who was like a little
nervous in the beginning she looked very
like stiff
but she got with it and honestly i don't
listen to of all the people probably i
was least familiar with ashley mcbride
and her music
but she performed this song that was so
everything like i think i'm on the way
to being in ashley mcbride
you know what like it was called like
martha something it is time
for us to become ashley mcbride stands
there's absolutely no reason
why we've never listened to one first
song she wins so many awards
grammys she's in our favorite genre i
don't
we love women in country music like it's
honestly offensive that i don't give her
the time of day
and this song i was just like living for
her vibe she just like gives no [ __ ]
and i could just
the performance definitely turned me
into a fan without knowing anything like
it was really good
i'm really glad to hear that he was the
third co-host sarah highland no no you
sent her kane brown who's everything of
the sort oh everything and honestly
after seeing him on the home edit show
which i also want to talk about
um i just like love him and his wife and
i feel like they have like a really
normal life
even though he like is so famous um i
have a theory about why the country
music awards are doing virtual shows
better
because i think like when you distill
the music down like country music really
is
is founded on like a man and his guitar
you know and that's easier to translate
and you can do like solo performances
much easier versus like pop is so much
about like the theatrics
but see i'm not saying i don't think the
i think the performance is at all award
shows
are fairly the same no matter if they're
remote or not
i just think that like the way that they
flow and they script and they have the
fake music and they have the different
stages they
in both the cma and the cmt awards they
took over all of nashville they had a
stage downtown to east west
it's not about the performances it's
really just about the vibe and even the
billboard music awards and i love kelly
clarkson
had a very awkward tone to it and i find
that these viral shows
when there's no audience not viral
remote shows when they
when they don't have an audience there
is that awkward element yeah and i don't
feel that way at any of the country
music awards that's the country
difference
very interesting luke holmes opened the
show
beautiful what did he sing five four
three two one too many and at the end
brooks and dunn came out and they shot
gun to beer and it was just like truly
like the show started just like that no
co-host it just opened
the commercial love to see it straight
to luke homes it was
you could tell literally everyone hadn't
been on stage in so long that they were
just
living for like this performance and i
was living for the performance
also new luke homes music comes out
friday tomorrow
[Music]
tomorrow
[Music]
it's so exciting um it's just exciting
you know
no it's never been a better time to be a
country music fan or a redhead
no that's the thing about being a
redhead it's never been a better time
and it's always
a good time it really is like the
perfect hobby i just want to if i may
just go off on the redheads really
quickly because it's such a great
community like the we still have a
functioning facebook group where people
share and art animals to each other that
they're reading yeah and then
you get to read a book and we try and
choose books like that have good reviews
and so we have good conversations around
them
and then there's a podcast dedicated to
like all of our thoughts and we all
always feel differently about the book
so like somewhere in one of the four of
us like
your opinion will be voiced right you'll
feel heard i just think it's like a
really
it's a good hobby you know it's a good
way to spend your time
reading more listening to more of me and
my friends who are great
and so if you're ever if you're like
ever feeling like you want to pick up a
new hobby
might i suggest the redheads you know
it's great to feel like a part of
something
reading is great for you in your brain
and i just i actually cannot see one
downside
of becoming a redhead and that's just a
hobby worth taking up
yeah and we also share all the other
books that we read during month all four
of us so
you can get other book recommendations
we rate every book on a scale
of one to five they're very hard raiders
we are someone posted the funniest
comment about dana they were like
dana gives the most like insightful
reviews about the book that she's
reading she's like
powerful blank blank you know very
strong love the protagonist 2.5
1.8 right that's so funny oh my god um
just a little redhead humor so just
check it out you guys
check it out so worth your time thank
you for letting me
share my passions if i've learned
anything
from working on so many passion projects
it's that
that's what fuels you you know life is
full of things you don't want to do and
things you want to do and you have to
prioritize
both you do episodes drop the first
thursday of every month
easy as that um i think we should dive
in i think we just have like a lot of
ground to cover and i'm really looking
forward to giving my thoughts on claire
and her prom
so it's the top of the store it's the
first story just for you
do you mind if i take it today the first
story no
the um the that's nice that you need to
know oh
sure it is time for the past five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
thank you um and also sorry i know i
keep like talking over you but what
would a day the morning choice be if i
didn't do just that
oh really quickly speaking of talking
over people
i don't want to like i don't need to
formally put it in the tv recap segment
but did you watch the home edit show
no okay so i watched wow that was like a
no you're disgusted
you know what like i didn't watch it
because i think because you watched it
and it didn't seem like something i
needed to watch
okay so they got amazing celebrities on
it and so every episode was like a
celebrity and a real person and like the
celebrities house was
so clean that it really they just like
organized it and then the the real
people had like hoarders and
i i skipped through a lot of the real
people stuff because i really only tuned
in for the celebrity it's like they had
khloe kardashian rhys witherspoon
i had seen their tv show on att um hello
sunshine
reese's production company that kind of
discovered them i think they sold that
show to netflix
um and the whole show was built around
like their organization skills and if
you're into organizing it's like very
pleasurable i actually feel like i
learned a lot about like dimension and
there's a real science to it they did
rachel zoe's closet which was sick
but there is this like weird
vibe between the two girls um one of
them and it like reminds me
i feel like it must be what people say
about me and you because like one of
them talks
all over the other girl but like we're
so different because
the one who talks over the other girls
like so mean to her like
she just like puts her down constantly
and i feel like
these two girls like definitely hate
each other like but they built such a
successful brand like literally like a
multi-million dollar brand they have
products in the container store they
have this tv show on netflix like their
instagram their clients like
they they did khloe kardashian's house
before the tv show like she's been a
long-time client same with rachel zoe
and i just like could not get over the
vibe between them and it made me really
sad because like
no business can survive it was so toxic
like that is so crazy and you know that
they're like
reeling it in and like being normal for
the show but it's like still sleeping
out like just so mean
one of them is just so domineering and
like talks over and puts down the other
one and then the more
i watched i felt like the one who was
being put down was kind of like
the the brains behind more of the
organization i think the other girl made
it into like more of a business but like
the science of like tall for short stack
dimension
i was getting the vibe that it was the
blonde girl even though the blonder was
like constantly being put down honestly
now i want to watch it because now it
sounds interesting yeah no it was there
one episode i don't want to watch the
whole thing is there one episode you
would recommend
um probably
rachel's oh okay because it was very
sickening to be inside her closet
and it had the most work to be done
because like she had come to their house
they had they had done
her closet like months ago and she had
gotten so much new stuff and like i just
kind of lived in the closet
so it wasn't terribly messy but it was
overflowing with stuff and it was like
sickening to see all of her stuff
okay done yeah i have so much on my
content plate
i know like my cup runneth over
i'm sorry i just had to get that in um
but speaking of
your rls i just wanted to say i did
speak to a few
kind of eccentric like eastern medicine
doctors
who did say that certain um like
medicines and
procedures for rdh can also be applied
to rls
interesting yeah i thought that was
really really interesting um what is
what are one of those
procedures i'm so glad you asked well
you know today's thursday and so of
course today's episode is brought to you
by thursday boots just in time for the
start of boot season we received a few
of the new releases from our friends at
thursday boots
i got the most sickening pair of white
booties like white booties are such like
a thing
and snatcher wears them all the time and
i just want to be just like snatcher and
i got a fabulous pair
from thursday boots and they have like a
nice little heel or pointed toe they're
super shiny i
love them i love thursday boots i just
got a pair of white combat boots
um from their new collection that are so
sickening and i just feel like
combat boots are the boot of the season
i agree and the white booties that you
got i got them
last year with cherries on them and
what's they have a nice sized heel but
what's so amazing about them is i
remember i wore them all day like from
the toast
to midnight and my feet did not hurt at
all for a heel like that is incredible
i stand thursday boots for those who may
not remember thursday boots is an nyc
based startup brand that designs really
really comfortable high quality boots
and sells them at the best direct to
consumer price they handcraft their
boots in the same north american and
european facility as brands that charge
two to four times the price
so by cutting out the retail markups
they offer the highest quality boots at
a very accessible price point and they
sell them directly to you
and if there ever was a year to invest
in more comfortable boots it's now
if you want fast fashion or shoes that
rarely make it out of your closet do not
shop at thursday boots
thursday boost is an investment in
comfort timeless styles and staples that
will last
for years you deserve more comfortable
boots without the high retail markup
because thursday boots is all about
year-round honest pricing
at the lowest sustainable market
possible they never have sales or
discounts
but they are going to give our listeners
free two-day shipping on the first order
and always offer free returns and
exchanges so you have nothing to lose
trying out your first pair
go to thursdayboots.com toast
and you can have a pair on your doorstep
before next thursday
that's oh yeah their shipping is
incredible um t-h-u-r-s-d-a-y-b-o-o-t-s
dot com slash toast for free two-day
shipping plus free returns and exchanges
from thursday boots
it's absolutely everything of the sort
and just just listen us okay
yeah everything of the sort okay first
story
um in what we're calling prom gate
bachelorette claire crawley is firing
back at claims that she lied about not
attending prom
so yesterday a user posted on instagram
we posted it on the morning toast if you
want to see the exact images
of her husband at prom in 1999
with what appears to be claire crawley
wait first of all before we get into the
details the pictures were so 90s like
claire's hair she literally looks like a
character from never been kissed
she really really did and she had said
on the show on tuesday nights
she said that she didn't have the great
greatest high school experience and that
she never went to prom so then and she
said
i just like was like invisible she said
nobody ever asked me nobody even knew
who i was in high school i was just
invisible i think i felt invisible
so of course this picture went viral
this picture surfaced it looks like
claire's at prom there's a corsage and
also we're like okay
she's lying and then claire commented on
the instagram post i have so many
problems with her response that's where
my
my real qualms lie she said
you do know there is more dances in high
school that are not prom turns out it's
just someone digging up old photos
why she keeps her husband's old dance
picks i'm not sure i went to a new
school senior year and in fact i did not
go to prom just like i said
okay so two things here her grammar is
bothering me so much in the first
sentence
second of all um i don't know why she's
like throwing shade at someone for
keeping
photos from your high school dance like
that's why you take those memories so
that 50 years later you can show your
grandchildren them like it's
that's like literally the point of
pictures
are the pictures you know that's just
like a weird hill to die on like
we need to keep pictures like no it's
literally the point of pictures it's the
point of taking them no i totally agree
and also
someone commented this on our instagram
it just made me laugh like why is it a
flex on the bachelor to not have gone to
prom
no it's like it's a thing every year
yeah i just whether you went to prom or
not neither here nor there
clearly there were many other dances and
so i don't think claire was like lying
about not going to prom
but what she went to look very prom like
so i understand why the woman was like
wait no my husband went to broadway by
the way i don't fault the woman at all
like if literally my husband
went to prom with someone famous and
they were like i didn't go to prom you
know i would literally be thirsting out
like
i don't blame her at all she went
private i feel like she was getting like
a lot of hate i feel really bad for her
um but i just want to say like while
this isn't a lie she definitely did not
go to prom this is like a junior dance
it is misleading to say i didn't have a
good high school experience
i was invisible when now you're saying
no i switched
schools senior year and didn't go to
prom so like it just
it seems like you're like a like a
an attend like it seems like a ploy for
sympathy
yes it does but i will say i don't know
why i constantly feel
find myself defending claire no please
but on this i must say like as someone
who switched schools in high school it's
awful
and i switched my sophomore year and i i
found it to be extremely difficult
her switching her senior year like that
is kind of traumatizing that is all i'll
say 100
but that doesn't give you a bad high
school experience when three out of four
years
seem to be fine and also it's like this
is such an interesting story because no
one here is lying matt
like and even maybe the woman who posted
it like maybe it was her husband senior
prom but claire was like a junior
and so she didn't go to her singer prom
but she has been to prom
you know no the thing is is that like
claire is telling the truth
yeah but it the way she kind of phrased
it was very misleading and if you're
going to go on tv you have to know that
like
every person from your past is going to
be like i saw claire in the bathroom
much and she didn't say hi to me like
that's just the world that we live in
like everyone like wants to get on the
claire
train yeah and i just think the way she
phrased it and what she said was
incredibly misleading and it's like
it just seemed like a ploy for like
sympathy like
what you're the most beautiful girl in
the world claire i would take you to my
prom
yeah you know yeah i feel you and that's
what girls do when they date
they lie but you're on tv and you gotta
lie better
that's what we're saying that's
literally what we said yesterday yeah
totally i actually um spoke to brandon
the guy who we had like gotten to the
most heated debate about he did
what's gonna take down this show no
literally like we agree on everything
except for our brand nothing can come
between us i just want to say i got like
a lot of jams people supporting my side
most people did take your side yes i'm
right
um i spoke to him in the dms yesterday
uh he really was not speaking english i
could not understand like what he was
saying but
he seemed to have no hard feelings
towards claire oh that's good to know so
yeah like so mature she probably made
the wrong choice i don't think he was
like the guy that she thought that he
was yeah no and i'm like getting all
bent out of shape on his behalf and like
he doesn't even care you know
it really did not make me feel good that
is so true yeah like i need to relax
like i need to stop taking battles that
like are not mine
no and that's i feel like that's the
plight of being like a reality
television fan it's like we get
so invested in like these things on
behalf of other people but like they've
moved on you know
they don't even care especially by the
time it aired like everyone has moved on
totally okay next story anna wintour
and shelby bryan split after 20 years
together
so this is giving me like total devil
wears prada vibes because
she said by the way and devil wears
prada is based on anna wintour right
like
loosely it's vogue okay the woman who
wrote the book was working at vogue and
so the experiences are what the woman
experienced as
anna wintour's assistant yes and that
conversation
in paris where she's like you know what
they're gonna say
she uh stone cold whatever
sends another one packing and i feel
like
the the headlines that i'm seeing are
like and i went to her finally so it's
like everyone knew that this marriage
was over
well so there's a lot of interesting
facts here per page six okay
and when tour and telecom millionaire
shelby bryan have finally split after
more than 20 years together page six is
told
page six had previously reported that
things had cooled off between the
powerful pair and that they hadn't been
seen to get seen in public together for
some time
but now we're told they're done for good
it's not clear yet what caused the split
but the chatter around town was that
brian had gone back to his ex-wife
catherine bryan whose husband investment
banker damon mezzacappa
died in 2015. but sources close to
catherine tell us that she's not
back with brian who stepped out on her
when he began an affair with the conde
nast honcho back in 1990 oh my god this
is
so messy no but it's like yeah it's
messy but it all
it's like just what they say like how
you get them is how you lose them the
source just said that catherine and
shelby have kids together and are
friends so they're not back together due
to
the passing of her husband but some
people are saying that they are
oh my god this is so messy like imagine
imagine you're the first wife and it's
like
you're husband cheats on you with anna
wintour
20 years go by and then your husband
dies i mean this is so messy
rich people drama is truly fascinating
yeah and the fact that page six has like
all of the t
on this like this is what page six is
for yeah exactly this is the type of
news that like only page six writes
about and cares about
right because they really have their ear
to their to the ground and it's like
very new york centric right
also they had reported that in november
things began to sour between the couple
um back in 2013 after it was revealed
that he owed
the irs about 1.2 million dollars in
back taxes so i think that's where the
finally comes from because it's like
there has been some chatter for a while
not like finally she left him very robin
dixon of him
yeah 1.2 million that's crazy
so it seems as though they are done no
more
do you think anna wintour's gonna like
hit the dating scene who do we ship her
with
oh that's an older gentleman like the
joseki's guy that's who she needs
but like not the actor because she
shouldn't be dating like an actor
like the character he plays um jeff
bridges
oh i think jeff bridges is like happily
married i'm sure that he is
i mean who wouldn't marry jeff bridges
most eligible man and be happy
yeah and jose riches was also in um
because i was trying to think like i
feel like we're always watching jeff
bridges and we can only come up with two
movies
he was in the fire movie we just watched
yes of course uh but that's only the
brave that wasn't on google
i just feel like if google like they're
so like in my business and
you know data getting my data and they
know what i like so when you're looking
at when you're
when i'm searching movies jeff
richardson like put the ones you know i
like at the top
such a good call like if you're not
gonna use my data to benefit me then
don't use it at all yeah like if you're
gonna spy on me at least make my life
easier 100
like like when you get an ad for
something that you hadn't seen before
that's like so you no i literally buy
from
my [ __ ] facebook ads all the time
they know me so well i got a pair of
boots last week
that are the cutest boots i've ever seen
in my life yes the pink ones yeah i
haven't had a chance to wear them i'm
having a hard time styling them
um but you guys are the cutest things
ever and i would have never seen them
without a facebook ad
so like that's you know that's when it's
like is the social dilemma a dilemma if
i'm getting new boots
right but then it's like stop buying
things you know yeah but then it's like
just show me the good jeff bridges
movies at the top that are catered
towards like my
needs needs and the information that you
have on me
i couldn't agree with you more i really
couldn't i just think that's fair to ask
i just think it's so interesting like
anna wintour's personal life adam which
was such an interesting celebrity to me
because
she's the type of person who's famous
for having a job do you know what i mean
most celebrities like are so famous and
they work a couple times a year doing
movies or whatever she's like a famous
corporate queen cog yeah like she goes
into kind of like world trade center
every day like to me people that's like
how also i feel about derek blasberg
like
and maybe it's like a fashion thing but
like people who are famous for having
jobs
also there are like other famous ceos
like bob
iger yeah but anna wintour is not a ceo
i don't think bob iger goes into the
disney office
every single day no i think that
literally he does no i think he travels
all around the world just like being
fabulous and doing disney work
also he's not the ceo anymore no but
like and also like now that's why i love
shark tank because we're getting like
famous nine to fivers right and it's
just so fabulous like derek blackburn
works for youtube like he works at
google you know like everyone else
yeah but i i think i feel like derrick
glassberg never goes to know he doesn't
not because he's always on a boat with
carly kloss
always yeah but like for google no free
like it's for the youtube branding yeah
no i think it's good branding i just
think it's an interesting group of
people like who are famous for their
jobs
not for like their well i guess your job
is like your talent but like
not like an actor or a singer like but i
would say anna winter is just as famous
as like many many pop stars you know
yeah
no it's a very good point thank you i
love making good points
um so that is an interesting story about
an interesting woman i can't wait to see
who she dates next
i feel like she's like probably the type
of person who like no actually i think
maybe she'll fall into another
relationship yeah
but she seems like a very independent
woman you know she does
but if she's been in a relationship for
20 years she seems like a relationship
kind of person that's true like
codependent
yeah borderline unhealthy yeah
sounds bad 20 years i don't know sounds
unhealthy
i disagree no i disagree too i'm just
joking okay
next up shonda rhimes reveals she left
abc for netflix after being refused
free disneyland pass so this is like
some bob iger drama too kind of
and i'm sure there's like such a like a
long road of like why she left but at
the end of the day like i don't
if i'm trying to rhymes like netflix
money versus abc money is like
incomparable oh for sure but listen to
the story
shonda rhimes opened up about her choice
to leave abc for netflix in 2017
after creating many hits for the network
sharing that her breaking point came
from an issue
with a disneyland ticket in the
hollywood reporter's october cover story
no this is it's like infuriating the
producer explained that despite
reportedly making over two billion
dollars for disney and earning millions
of dollars for herself
oh my god i thought she made two billion
dollars from disney i'm like girl stay
for them okay um including and earned
millions for herself
grey's anatomy she had a constant battle
with abc which is owned by disney
she said i felt like i was dying like
i've been pushing the same ball
up the same hill in the exact same way
for a really long time
her breaking point came in 2017 over a
trip to disneyland
as part of her contract the showrunner
had an all-inclusive pass
and had negotiated a second one for her
nanny however her past was not
interchangeable so when her sister
needed one
to take rimes's daughter to the park she
had to go back and forth with a network
and was told we never do this multiple
times the park eventually issued her an
extra pass
which would have cost 154 dollars but it
didn't work when her family arrived
rhymes then called a high-ranking
executive who allegedly asked her don't
you have enough
oh no no i mean first of all
that would bother me too it's like i'm
literally taking this company i built
this park
and let me in i totally understand with
that she called her lawyer and asked to
go to netflix like
that is so infuriating to like first of
all disney passes
for everyone forever just send like 50
in the mail
yeah and to show up and not be able to
get into the park and it's like
china rhymes with sister like i am with
her child and it's like i have a million
kids
like going to disney is not like going
to the park like it is literally a
journey with the children in the car
seat and the snacks and the nanny like
it's a true journey and to go all the
way not to get in like that would bother
me so much too like i would quit my job
also
yeah no and i think that was just her
breaking point but i can see
exactly how that is a brain but it's
just like such a small thing that's
a no-brainer when someone is making you
billions of dollars also at the end of
the day like shonda rhimes is an
innovator and a genius and like we'll go
down in history as like one of the
greatest tv producers and creators of
all time
and we're in like a transitional time
right now where streaming services are
so far beyond cable that like
if if she had stayed at cable like i
actually think it would have been like
to her detriment
she's so forward thinking and netflix
they give you unlimited budgets
unlimited passes
all the ideas you want make a show and i
just think like that's
where she should be anyway i agree i
totally
like someone who has like her talent and
her success um
when abc was what it was at the height
of grey's anatomy was a perfect place
for her but now it's like
we're in the streaming wars like get on
board yeah
100 so but you know i guess she could
have done that for disney plus
if they had really utilized her talents
properly true
true it's funny how i don't even think
about disney plus like in the streaming
wars
even though which is a great segue i
know to our next story disney plus is
probably one of my favorite
streaming services in terms of content
they offer and navigation experience
like
i find it very easily navigable i
totally agree oh but i thought you're
going to say disagree
and it's like whenever i don't have a
lot of tv shows but whenever i'm like
looking for a movie night
nine times out of ten what i'm looking
for is on disney plus
you can find like some real content
uppers on disney plus
100 and they'll always like take you
back to a different time in your life
when things were so simple yeah um i
know we have like a big streaming wars
um
update and i'm dying to talk about it
but i'm also dying to talk about how
today's episode is also brought to you
by liquid iv
is that okay that's so important for you
to say right now
the cooler weather is here and it makes
it easier to miss signs of dehydration
like overheating or perspiration which
means it's even more important to keep
your body properly hydrated
yes people think like summer gotta
hydrate no actually winter gotta hydrate
that dry skin
you gotta drink some water with one
stick of liquid iv in 16 ounces of water
you can get two to three times the
amount of hydration as plain water
so if you're like me and like drinking
water is kind of hard for you um i use
the liquid iv sticks because then i'm
taking that one glass of water and
making it like into two to three times
the hydration power and it's just it's
efficient for my time for my energy and
for my drinking water capacity because i
don't have that much capacity of
drinking water if you watch my comedy
special you know that
flu season all often lines up with your
holiday plans but liquid iv can help
support your immune system with like
increased hydration
and essential vitamins these crazy times
most of us haven't left our houses in so
long our immunity actually might be
lower
than it was before so liquid iv can help
support your immune system
with that increased hydration and the
vitamins uh that are in the packs so i
just think it's really important that
you take care of yourself because you
want you don't want to be missing on
holiday season like
we might be able to leave our houses
like come on um it's perfect for staying
hydrated on long flights long road trips
it can even get with
it can even help with hangovers after
those extra holiday drinks i mean we've
been saying forever like
yes like what is amazing for all the
scientific reasons but at the end of the
day you take one when you're hungover
and
nothing helps more and that's worth a
million dollars
excuse me liquid iv's best-selling
hydration multiplier
now has three flavors guava watermelon
and apple pie
um it's a fabulous product it really is
efficient for
saving time if you're like me and you
just can't really drink that much water
and great for hangovers which i know our
tipsy toasters will love
it's available nationwide at walmart in
the beverage section or you can get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com and use
the code toast at checkout
that's 25 off anything you order when
you use the promo code toast at
liquidive.com
get better hydration today at
liquidity.com promo code toast that's
l-i-q-u-i-d-i-v
dot com promo code toast and remember
that one serving of liquid iv
provides the same hydration as drinking
two to three bottles of water alone
and they're on a mission to change the
world the company has donated over 5
million
servings globally in response to cobia
19 their products are being donated to
hospitals first responders
food banks veterans active us military
over 3 million servings in total so far
so love it you have no choice but to
support
sign on get hydrated okay back to the
streaming wars because we have some
streaming news quibby officially
announces
that it is shutting down and if you
watched the morning toast back when we
were in our old studio
i literally called this like not to make
everything about me did you oh man yes
and that's
you know what happened like that's why
okay interesting here's the t
quivi the short form entertainment
service for mobile devices announced on
wednesday that it will shut down just
over six months after its service
launch the company which was founded by
hollywood producer jeffrey katzenberg
and former hp ceo meg whitman
raised 1.75 billion dollars ahead of its
launch in april
the app features short-form news and
entertainment videos or quick
bites hence kwai bye quibby running 10
minutes or less in length it attracted
top hollywood stars for its shows too
such as chrissy teigen and idris elba
investors in quibby included legacy
media companies like disney comcast
universal at
t's warner media to me this is so
interesting not that i i'm just not
shocked at all like
i feel as though i did predict this um
but i find it so interesting because
quibby had two things
and to me these two things equal success
almost always
unlimited money 1.7 billion dollars
unlimited money and unlimited access to
celebrities and celebrities on board
and the fact that a company with almost
every famous person in the world
every single one every big media company
behind it and all the money behind it
couldn't make a success like that's
what's shocking to me here
the format made no sense and honestly
the fact that it didn't succeed is not
surprising to me but the fact that it
had
all that behind it and still didn't make
it that's shocking no
it's extremely interesting like it's an
interesting
case study yep that with all of those
things like you still can't necessarily
guarantee that people are going to
download your app
and watch your stuff no it's it's
that's what's and that was the only
thing i'm like i don't really get the
need for this app
but the fact that literally chrissy
teigen joe jonas everyone was on it i'm
like it's of course going to be a
success because
celebrities are very effective marketers
yeah and with that plus all the money
right how could it not
and the content is so high quality i
will say though that it seems like
quibby
quibby's launch like the intention for
quibby was for people on the go
right that's short form content because
that's where we were all headed
pre-pandemic like we're getting faster
quicker shorter attention span come you
watch this watch this and we're watching
on our phone and we're not home at our
tvs and we just like want to get
snackable content and then all of that
changed and then quibby launched
like under the old pretenses but in the
new world and so i think
that already they were going
to have setbacks due to that but to be
like a complete
and like admitted failure in six months
is crazy
really really crazy but i mean it was
just really
not their time no but the thing is is
like and part of my frustration when we
first started talking about quibby was
like
people in the industry like i had been
in meetings with like different like
whatevers
for years people were talking about
quibby like i think the first time i
heard jeffrey katzenberg's quibby
was four years ago and it's like yeah
it's coming it's coming and literally
everyone's coming
and it's like first of all that big of a
lead time you're only gonna fail first
of all
second of all if they had come out four
years ago i actually think it would have
been ahead of its time and like maybe
had a chance of success but the fact
that it took so long to get here and
then the time it got here it was
in these unprecedented times was a
recipe for
disaster yeah this is interesting they
said in the announcement that it's
making a proactive
decision to preserve shareholder equity
and will return the remaining funds to
investors quibby alerted its investors
and employees of the news on wednesday
afternoon
they said while we have enough capital
to continue operating for a significant
period of time
we made the difficult decision to wind
down the business return cash to our
shareholders and say goodbye to our
talented colleagues with grace
i think that's for the best um and that
she said
meg whitman said we continue to believe
that there's an attractive market for
premium short form content
over the coming months we will be
working hard to find buyers for these
valuable assets who can leverage them to
their full potential
so what they're trying to do now is sell
off the shows that they created you know
like we
heard of chrissy's court and the other
one was um
like the legendary no literally
quibby was built on the back of christy
tegan that's like the only show i ever
watched i downloaded the app
and watched her episodes and then like
couldn't really find anything else to
watch i watched a couple episodes of
punk
but there were also shows yeah punk'd
and there were also shows that were like
meant to be like high
drama shows but that were 10 minutes so
they could sell
the scripts rights everything shows to
netflix and then netflix takes it and
does what it does
but that has so much con like no netflix
is always looking for content but that
hasn't happened yet like at the time of
this like i'm sure they were trying to
sell their shows for a while and no one
has bought anything the
right the um the report that i read said
that they tried and failed
yeah to sell most of their shows but meg
is saying that they're still on the
market
well i think chrissy teigen's show
should be sold to like a fox 5 i think
it would be fabulous i agree or even
like a bravo i feel like andy would love
it
yeah i think there's something there but
i feel like we're just being like
strangely optimistic when they're
literally telling us points like like
yeah this is a failure there's nothing
here yeah it's crazy there were a lot of
things about quibby that i thought were
um good not to be you know only negative
like when
we were using the app like the fact that
you could watch content that was filmed
both vertically and horizontally and you
could switch between and you would get
different
views that was very interesting
technology and i hadn't seen that before
yeah no it was made for a world on the
go and then
literally the world stopped moving
people stopped going
and then quibby launched yeah for people
on the go who are sitting at home who
have a tv right in front of them and
quibby is not on your television
yeah and it's like i'm i'm the queen of
watching stuff on my phone
and i downloaded quibby and i paid for
it for a few months and it was just n
i never felt compelled to open up the
app ever yeah
so it's an interesting case study
very for the streaming wars the first to
fall
the first to fall in the streaming wars
very sad
but our fifth and final story is some
exciting news for
us elwood stands legally bond three
is coming but the release is delayed to
2022.
everyone it's a real it's a real it's
not a virtual
zoom reunion everyone's favorite gemini
vegetarian is postponing her return to
the big screen legally
bond 3 has been pushed back its release
date and will debut on may 20th 2022.
reece witherspoon is reprising her
iconic role as sorority girl turned
lawyer l woods for the third installment
in the series
the three quill from mgm was initially
scheduled to open this february
but those plans were quietly derailed
even before the coronavirus pandemic
caused movie theaters to close
mindy kaling and dan gore wrote the
screenplay
a director has not been set yet nor have
additional cast members plot details
have also been kept under wraps oh so it
hasn't been filmed yet
no wait this first of all mindy kaling
being involved in the script like this
is gonna be good anyway and i'm gonna
see it anyway but it'll actually be
sensational
and i would like to um let's go back and
forth what you think the plot's gonna be
about because i just had a good idea
because now at this point probably ellen
emmett are definitely still married and
they have kids
and she's a working lawyer big time
lawyer um and she it's giving me the
vibe that like
her character a little bit in big little
lies like uh
little fires everywhere who she always
is like type a yeah
so uh elle's baby girl let's call her um
l junior is at school and there's like a
big dilemma at school like something
i don't know i can't figure out what it
was but they need a lawyer and
elle of course does the case pro bono
and the whole
epi the whole movie is like them
fighting for justice i don't know what
the qualm is at the school like maybe
they need to stop sign i don't know i'll
figure it out
but she becomes the pro bono legal
representative representative
for the school against the city i
actually have a really good idea
okay based on real life like which i
think always makes things more
agree i think that the writers might be
inspired by kim kardashian
okay and it might have like a criminal
justice reform
angle maybe it's like paulette gets
arrested for a crime and she gets an
unfair sentence
oh and then l takes on the work that
like kim is doing
in helping get her no i don't think
that's a good idea
because scent and shortening because the
movies are very light and so even like
the legal issues they deal with it's all
very
like light i think like no i don't think
they'll be too real for them
okay that's a good point but i could see
it i'm very interested to see what
happens i do think like l
in her personal life like we'll still be
married to emmett and we'll have kids of
course and if if they're not like i
don't want it
no no i'm not interested in seeing a
single l and i'm not interested in
like trouble between ellen emmett
because like we've had i don't know how
long 15 years with
ellen emman in our minds as like one of
the best couples ever and so i don't
want to know that maybe they weren't
no no it there's absolutely no
possibility that they're not together
like i will
like i'll riot okay we'll see what i
mean honestly 2022 is in so long like
i want to like be excited we'll watch
this episode
in two years and see if we were right
yeah
hey two years from now hey hope you're
doing well i hope you're doing that i
hope you're alive
i hope you're like better than i am now
yeah um
and i just like what's good that's
interesting we should do a time capsule
video for ourselves
like zoey that we should watch when this
movie comes out
whatever it is i love that idea that's
hilarious
um okay were those all the stories those
were all the stories and i feel as
though you needed to know them
um so let's dive into tv recap we have
oc housewives and the david letterman
show to do we'll start with the david
letterman show please
um and the david letterman show recap is
brought to you by bruce
literally i can't you know what else is
brought to you by bruce
these babies it is the best product
i've ever owned for it has really
transformed brushing my teeth like i can
feel like a more clean and clear
mouth when i'm done brushing i think my
breath is significantly better i'm being
dead serious from starting the brush i
don't think i was like for the last
couple years like brushing my teeth
properly no i agree and also i
i've always had this issue with bringing
a toothbrush on me with me on trips
like i never do and then i never have a
toothbrush and it's just always my cross
to bear but the bruce comes in like this
really cute travel case so i'm
always bringing my bruce with me on
trips so like i never miss a day of
brucing
so brushing your teeth is a chore but
bruching them
is very fun and it's a hundred times as
effective bruce cleans your teeth at 31
000 movements a minute manual
toothbrushes tap out at just 300
movements a minute
many electric toothbrushes are barely a
step up from the manual ones
some do a good job but they cost over
200 dollars bruce delivers
premier sonic wave technology without
the markups that big electric
toothbrushes tack on
so it's just as effective as some of
like the most expensive brushes
out there but first of all it's so cute
i have the like
baby pink one and it's just like a
fabulous thing to have on my counter it
makes me feel very like grown up
um it's very reasonably priced and it
works so well there's no reason to get
an electric toothbrush that's not the
brush i'm telling you
um and if you want to get 15 off your
brush use promo code toast at bruce.com
brush your spell to b-r-u-u-s-h dot com
try it 90 days risk-free and get a
two-year warranty at bruce.com
promo code toast check it out trust us
on this one trust us on this one sign on
start brushing
change your mouth forever okay so let's
dive into i actually took notes from the
kim
episode and then i want to talk about
the other two that i watched okay
i just want to talk about kim for a
minute because yesterday was her 40th
birthday
and like i just love and adore her so
much everything about her like she can
do no wrong in my eyes like she is icon
status
forever my respect all the way up here
and forever forever
dave letterman came this [ __ ] close
to ruining the entire episode
first of all like let her speak yeah
anytime she was like about she like
would answer this question then was
about to like launch into like a another
statement like
he would cut her off with a bad [ __ ]
joke
and i hate when like i've not watched
that many of his episodes but i always
feel like he's laughing at his guests
i i know what you mean i actually didn't
think that i didn't feel that way about
dave chappelle i felt like he had
so much respect i haven't watched that
one yet though but i agree it's like
so part of me agrees and part of me
disagrees because
that interview that kim and courtney did
on the letterman show years ago that
like went viral where he was just like
so
nasty like so you're like famous for
having no talent like it was so weird
i like that he actually brought that up
and like owned it and apologized and i
feel like he has enormous respect for
like
what she's done in pop culture what
she's done for um
prison reform but i did feel like there
was this underlying tone just being like
so like who makes more money you're
kanye like i just i didn't love his tone
yeah or like when she came out and the
first thing he asked was like about her
braid and like how much it costs like
who the [ __ ] cares yeah no it was like a
little condescending like oh your little
girl with your makeup and your hair
like of all the people to get the
opportunity to like interview someone
so iconic i was like annoyed that it was
him but i did think that he touched on
everything i wanted him to touch on i
didn't even think of like the oj stuff
like and he actually asked our point
playing like
who do you think did it and what did she
say i think she didn't really give a
name she didn't give an answer out of
respect for his children which
then again my respect my queen all the
way up here it's like she thinks of
everything like as a mom and she knows
that
oj's kids like she's not gonna just like
go out and call o.j a murderer like even
though most people would
i just everything she did was just like
giving me life
i loved that they had chris courtney
chloe and kanye in the audience with
like a light on them i think it added
like a whole other
and who tracy her friend oh my god i
love that i think it like added a whole
other dimension to the interview like
seeing their reaction especially with
the parisian like seeing chris and
courtney like get so emotional
it was brilliant just brilliant beyond
brilliant
the other thing that i um wrote down um
was he when they were talking about her
prison reform work and
she was talking about how like everyone
told her not to go to the white house it
would ruin her
reputation but she was like i'm not
gonna protect my reputation over saving
someone's life which i thought was
really insightful
he then asked like the strangest
question was like
do you think that that opens the
corridor of visibility and viability to
democracy
and no it was honestly worse than that
you know some people like most people
would have just like
did not want it to seem like dumb and
like would have bullshitted like
i think the corridor of viability for
democracy is definitely open
and she was like i literally have no
idea what you just said and like i don't
even know if he knows
what he didn't know what he said no one
in the audience knew what he had said no
one watching
because it was like uh such like say
what like what is your question ask your
question plain english like
the rest of the interview was not spoken
in old english so why is this one
question it was so bizarre
and i just loved her response like it
was just so real and like part of the
reason why i love her it's like she owns
completely who she is
yeah she really really does it was
wonderful just to watch her and like to
see her
in a different way than we're used to
seeing her but i really
like it made me like dislike david
letterman
more than i already did i mean him in
the cvs
i really didn't have an opinion before
never thought about him a day in my life
like literally never saw like
never think of him i find him i found it
to be so annoying the cvs like with the
battery swallowing like
that's your best joke like this is the
best comedian i swallowed a battery like
i just i i couldn't get it and i'm about
to say something really really
controversial like
really controversial but like david
letterman is super old
and he's been on television for years
and i feel like when he got his start
in comedy and on television the
the amount of people who could become
famous and get on tv was very narrow it
was like men straight men white men like
it was very narrow
and now we're living in a world where
anyone with a phone can become famous
and i think that like if david letterman
was 20 years old now
he never would have gotten a tv show
there are comedians who are
far superior to him in in writing and
comedy
and i just think that was really evident
where like he's with the most famous
person in the world in a cvs and like
his joke about swallowing batteries not
only did he say it like
four times he couldn't let it go yeah
let it go put it on his instagram like
not funny yeah and we oh also david
letterman like we get it like
you're old like get another joke yeah
like we see your beard you're old we get
it
no where's the lie where's the lie sorry
and i know that's controversial but
it's true no i hear you here are my
other notes
i loved the conversation about caitlyn
um first of all that those little
nuggets that i didn't know like when
when um kim had walked in on bruce in
women's clothing and like ran to
courtney's house and he called her said
don't tell your mother
very very interesting we did you have
heard that we did know that but
hearing it being told like from kim's
mouth like
in just like story form like painted a
picture for me yes and
also we heard that story i think it
probably was around the time
where caitlyn was trans transitioning
but now like five years out from
that time like it's interesting to hear
the whole story from start to finish
yeah and the for me like one of my
favorite parts of the interview was
both david letterman and kim gave
caitlyn credit for like the
barriers she broke down um coming out as
transgender and i feel the exact same
way like
i feel like caitlyn jenner has become
like a little bit of a joke like in pop
culture just because like she's like
kind of thirsty
um but i think it's not important that
we not forget like at the time
when bruce became caitlyn and that
interview with diane sawyer
it was unheard of like it was so crazy
and
i agree like she became the face and i
don't know if the transgender community
is so happy about it but but she
became the face the public face for a
lot of people
of transgenders yeah and the trans
community and
i love that they gave her that respect
because she's become a joke
in in our culture and it's sad but
she what she did was incredibly brave
yeah and i think that
however we remember it now i think at
the time
it was one of those things where it's
like everybody like
it was a it was a huge cultural moment
and a learning lesson for so many people
and i think that even though
people might not remember how they felt
before versus how they felt after
they they still feel that way about the
after exactly like the disrespect that
we all had
towards caitlyn like before we knew what
she was going through
is not something that would happen again
because like she
did that the first through the wall is
the bloodiest and that was caitlyn
jenner
not that she's like the first
transgender famous person ever but she
is one of the
most famous and one of the earliest yeah
so and the most mainstream yes so i
loved that part of the interview like it
gave i and i know that it's hard for
them to talk about caitlyn because of
what they perceive caitlyn did to chris
but the fact that they gave that respect
towards her like i really appreciate it
yeah
and then of course the pinnacle of the
interview was the the the stuff about
paris
yeah which i never can hear her talk
about without like
sobbing like hysterically crying seeing
chris cry made me cry
seeing chris and courtney hold hands
made me cry hearing kim say that
and the way she said it i thought was so
interesting like as if it's like routine
for women she was like all right this is
it like this is the time that i'm going
to get raped like
the way that she said it just like
really sent chills up and down my spine
and then how the whole time she's in the
bathtub with the concierge begging him
she didn't speak french
begging him to tell them that she has
kids like she has a family she has a
husband and all she could think about
was courtney coming home and like being
traumatized
by kim's dead body like that's she was
sad that she was gonna have
inflicted that on courtney yeah i also
thought it was so interesting when she
said
she was like just thank god that it
happened to her and not any of her other
siblings because
most people like literally anyone else
would be scarred for life
from something that traumatizing but
she's just like so mentally tough that
it really feels as though she's
unfazed unphased and like dealt with it
yeah i just feel like that's something
that would always linger and i'm sure in
a part
like it does and it affects so many of
her decisions going forward but like
that trauma i feel like lives with you
for anyone lives with you forever but
like she
and dave did touch on this when he was
like
what you've been through in your
lifetime like all of the things just one
of those things is what
one person goes through in a lifetime
whether it's like your parents being
involved in the
middle of a murder trial right whether
it's your sex tape
your sex tape whether it's the robbery
whether it's your
stepdad transitioning in front of the
entire world like there are just so many
things and we always say this about them
that it's like
it's always the craziest thing that
happens next yeah
no i totally agree and speaking of the
sex tape really quickly
i really appreciated that conversation i
feel like that conversation as it
pertains to kim
has never actually been had i feel like
paris hilton's starting to have those
conversations about how like
it was such a big scandal like everyone
was giving them [ __ ] and they were like
canceled
when at the end of the day it was an
incredible invasion of privacy
and they were really the victims of
those acts whereas like everyone's like
she's sold or sex hyped to get famous
people love to say that about kim and
paris
when at the end of the day these were
two young girls who had questionable
judgment
as any young person does and their
privacy was invaded so wholly and like
literally everyone in the world has like
seen them naked and having sex and like
the way that she just spoke about
they've been through some of the
craziest things and they always get to
get through it just by sticking together
and like being a family i think it's
just like a wonderful
message to send yeah i just i i could
i wish the interview was three hours
longer and like david letterman and and
with a different host who like had more
understanding like you know she doesn't
just post a picture and sell four
million dollars in skims
no it's so it's so belittling to
everything that she does and i actually
think he has so much respect for her
but i just if i were i just felt like
you know she was always like yeah yeah
dave are you
[ __ ] done yeah and he literally just
like kept trying to do stand up like
in the middle which is my least favorite
quality like you're gonna stand up
you're gonna interviewing like let's
keep them separate like
it was just frustrating it was just
looking for a joke anywhere and honestly
kim was funnier than him i said it
i said it oh my gosh kim she said
something
so funny she was just like so quick yes
she's very on her feet and she's
her posture i couldn't stop looking at
like she's so poised and elegant
and also she would like say something
and i'm like okay let's go down
let's travel down this road and he would
just like move on move on like when she
said the story about how she was pulling
up to her dad's house
and then the press reported that it was
a mistress and that was like her first
experience with like how
the media the media can like like just
really say things that are untrue she
was like and that was my first
experience and it's like
elaborate what was your second yeah yeah
no i totally agree
it wasn't long enough yeah i i i need
that
with a different interviewer four hours
long yeah but i still really really
enjoy
and i'm glad like this is a very serious
show that he does they're a very serious
guest echo what goes
on so credit to david letterman i mean i
i just don't feel like he needs credit
for having like the most famous
impressive like incredible woman
but like thank you for for having her on
even though like duh
yeah duh um the other episodes that i
watched i should have watched him in a
different order because after kim like
i just couldn't get off that high the
dave chappelle one was
very good they filmed it you know he
lives like in a random town in ohio and
he like never moved to hollywood so he
says he doesn't really feel
like a celebrity he feels like a famous
person and he would much rather be
famous
than be a celebrity because fame comes
with like money and benefits whereas
celebrity comes with
invasiveness red carpets like constant
effort for sure and i just
i just want to preface i haven't watched
it yet i'm literally going to watch it
today so i want to hear your thoughts
but like try not to
i won't spoil it but the ohio was
basically like
the whole interview like his obsession
with just like the concept of community
and that's why he lives there he's like
tim like here yes i'm famous like i'm
really just saving the people here
protect me
and i moved here when the whole
chappelle show drama happened like
nobody was selling stories to paparazzi
or taking pictures
everyone here protected me and he just
like is obsessed with not only his town
it has an
unbelievable history like because ohio
was an abolitionist state
so during the times of slavery like
black people weren't slaves but they
also weren't free and it was just like
this
incredible community that's like very
progressive and
very um welcoming for everyone and very
supportive of the black lives matter
movement
and it's just like this life he has
there is so interesting and it's just
like not what you would think
for the most famous person in the world
and
the conversations were a lot the most
interesting parts to me were the parts
about
um his brand of comedy being like kind
of offensive and he's like
i don't set out to like make people cry
like i'm not writing a joke and honestly
of course that notion that someone
watches me tunes in and gets upset
is painful i don't want to be that but
he just feels so strongly about his
right to say it that it overwhelms
whatever pain he might be feeling and
dave really attributed like
dave dave letterman really attributed
dave chappelle with kind of saving
stand-up comedy and so many comedians
feel that way
and i totally agree it's 100 sure there
should be this reserved space within our
culture
where you're free to joke and of course
we like within reason but
that should exist and dave chappelle is
really like the cornerstone of that that
was super interesting
and then dave's take on like police
brutality and the black lives matter
movement was so interesting because dave
letterman said like
and i felt this way too like when george
floyd was murdered like
so many people look to dave chappelle
like as a leader
and they want to hear what you have to
say and dave is like well you know
i don't want to be a leader like malcolm
x died broke
i don't want to be a leader i just want
to be myself and it was just like a
and i felt the same i felt like dave and
i was really i actually think he did a
way better
job letterman i think letterman did a
way better job interviewing dave
chappelle just because they're probably
more similar comedy whatever
um and i felt like dave letterman was
really speaking for me because like
it's true so many people from all
different walks of life look to dave
chappelle he's been talking about
you watch his specials from 15 20 years
ago
about being black in america it feels
like it was written today like he's been
doing this for so long and so he is
through his unwillingness become a
leader in the movement and
someone people look up to and i don't
think he wants that it was just like
interesting to hear him
speak on it when he just he just wants
to
be himself not a great leader or a great
thinker but he is
interesting i'm excited to watch it
because it will sounds like i will have
more respect and appreciation for david
letterman when i didn't
oh and david letterman yes yes and i
didn't think my respect for dave
schumacher getting higher
again and then even more than i already
do for dave chappelle so
then after watching those two i watched
lizzo's and to be honest i only got
halfway through it and it wasn't because
it was bad but it's just dave letterman
was annoying me so much like
you had three hours dave letterman
because you want to know why i feel like
dave letterman knows nothing about lizzo
and i feel like he knows a little bit
about kim a lot about dave chappelle and
i feel like he knew nothing about lizzo
so it's like
i don't need you to explain to me that
her name is melissa jefferson like it
was just so
basic maybe it's because she's newer on
the scene but
i just felt like he didn't do any
research and it was annoying
interesting okay i'm gonna watch both of
those today
and let you know my thoughts it's a
really it's a great show
and letterman is annoying i didn't watch
robert downey jr because i just like
don't care yeah um so i won't be
watching that but if you haven't seen it
there's old episodes kanye did an
episode there's a bunch of good people
in there i watched the kanye ones
there's a bunch of people in the first
and second seasons and it's worth your
time if you
live and breathe and die for celebrities
which i believe you do if you're
watching the show
i believe you do as well real housewives
of orange county yes
you know what i'm cautiously optimistic
about this season like
i i'm not hating it as much as i thought
i would and as much as i've hated some
of the seasons that we've been watching
of other franchises like being weak yeah
i have a few initial thoughts
first of all we're having the opposite
problem of what we usually have which is
like it takes a few
episodes for the women to get back into
their groove because they haven't seen
each other we're having the opposite
problem
these women see each other all the time
there's so much drama from the last six
months that happened off camera because
they're always like
calling each other now it's very small
we talk every single day some of them
like some of them are really close
friends their kids hang out like
we're catching up with the drama that's
unfolded so i think that that's like
interesting and
we're just like straight out it's
banging out of the canon
and to me this bronwyn gina fight is
very interesting so you told me
which i don't recall that i am like a
gina stan apologist so last year like
you were
so like riding on gina and like trying
to get me to see the light and like
towards the end
you did get me a little bit but i'm so
far back yeah no and this fight between
gina and bronwyn i'm completely team
bronwyn same and in the oc
usually in other franchises i have
people who i will ride for no matter if
they're writers
no no no i don't have that in the oc i
feel like you have that with shannon
adore
i don't i actually just weirdly i just
given shannon like a pass because i
think that
what she's gone through in the last few
seasons is like extreme
yeah so i just i've i've treated her
like i've given her a little bit of a
special treatment for sure but that ends
because now she's in a good
that ends today no but um i just like in
potomac like monique i have your back
yeah in new york bethany i have your
back
beverly hills jarite erica like i have
your back so
i don't have that in the oc and i just
whenever fight is going on i just take
the side of the person who i think is
right in the fight and nothing else
i feel like that's how you're supposed
to like watch housewives all the time
yep so i guess last season i really just
thought that gina was right even though
i don't like
love or or hate her and this season i
think that bronwyn is right
i think that everything now starting
with gina and the hus and bronwyn's
husband's text
now that gives context like why there's
like tension
tension between them i mean her making a
mountain out of a molehill with that tax
like
chill and no offense like her husband
doesn't want you gina like go get your
hair cut okay
um damn her hair is so tragic
it means i'm gonna cry i went to bed and
i said seven hail mary's for her hair
and every season it's like new and worse
new and worse and worse it's awful
also i feel like bronwyn's husband sure
that tags like
it wasn't like the winky face was a
little it's not like the average text
you get
you know six year old man texts
different than me also like
bronwyn's husband's energy like he's
just like a smiley different sort of guy
i think a hippie i feel like and him
sending a wink like
isn't the same as someone else sending
away i agree and
to have held on to that have an emoji it
was an emoticon like
you're thinking wait you're honestly
semicolon and a parenthesis
yeah like he's in a different like
universe yeah i totally agree
it was so nothing and like her running
around like you know inferring like oh
he
was so rude and it's so immature and if
i were broadway i'd be talking [ __ ]
about her little house too
because what gina did is far worse than
calling her house small which at the end
of the day
small is not a mean word it's fact it's
a small house it's not a big deal
yeah um and there's gina emily getting
drunk and calling bronwyn was just like
no
so [ __ ] messy like and bronwyn on the
one hand say to my face in two like
we're on a tv show so
let's film this conversation we're the
biggest fight in the franchise right now
like
i'm not having this conversation with
you while you're drunk on emily's phone
yeah huh but quickly to emily i and i
can say this i'm not embarrassed like
since season one i felt like there's
real potential with emily
and i think she's been derailed by a lot
of her insecurities her derailment on
her friendship with gina i think
definitely made her really insecure
within the group
um but now we're at a place where i
think that vicky and tamara gone like
really gives
lens a space for emily to be fun and we
get to see fun emily and billy be
herself
and i think also her new hip is like a
life changer and i like love hearing
about it like
i am an emily like really big fan and
her um
intro tagline about stealing something
about being with something about her
curves like i just [ __ ] love her
and i think that this is gonna be the
season of emily i said it
yeah if i were emily it would bother me
when people like every time i ordered a
drink people are like are we gonna see
fun emily
like that just like bothers me that when
people say that it is annoying and if i
were her
it would really [ __ ] bother me it's
like one year implying that unless i'm
drinking i'm not fun and like that's
just a mentality problem that people
like
have to and that's literally what
bronwyn is about to struggle with like
people will think she's not fun because
she's not drinking
those comments are exacerbated you can
be fun without alcohol
right so like it that would just bother
me it's hard
and like i don't know it just like
triggers me no i agree
it's like rude yeah it is rude it's like
deeply insulting to their character
yes i totally agree but i think she's a
very good friend she's a little too
excited for like taking the doors down
no i know she's got to slow down
or roll no but someone has to like i
love shannon
i love her too and i'm so happy for her
in her life it's really weird that
tamara is like a big part of the
conversation and she's not on the show
she's moving things around i feel like
maybe tamara got fired at the last
minute and she was like laying
groundwork for the next season
before she got fired that's what it
feels like yeah it's it's weird to like
be speaking of like the ghost of tamar's
past and like she's not even on his
friend like it's not like when vicki was
like
maybe in maybe out i'm surprised they
don't cut out the timer conversation
entirely but i guess it's germaine to
the storyline also
um emily and gina did have it when they
were they were being really mean about
bronwyn but they did say something
interesting like about her house like
renting an 8 000 square foot house and
like
how a lot of their money smoke and
mirrors because bronwyn is a housewife
but i don't think she has a job
otherwise like what does he do
it isn't interesting i would love to
hear more
i'm sure that we will i'm sure someone
is going to bring it up to her but on
bronwyn i'm so
proud of her i think that becoming sober
especially when you're a reality star on
a reality show that is centered around
drinking we've seen it a few times like
um people going on this journey and i
think it's extremely
brave and it takes a very strong person
and i am very
proud of her i agree and i think it's a
great message to be sending yeah
and i like the new housewife a lot
actually oh yeah she reminds me of like
so many different people i can't even
put my finger on it
so when in her interviews i was wanting
to say this and i knew you weren't going
to agree with me she's
her mannerism's not looks her mannerisms
give me like a little luandala steps
vibes
i don't see it i know um but she does
look like someone who i can't put my
finger on but it will
come to me to me no one's gonna see this
either because i
have a different set of eyes i guess but
she remind like it's not the one who she
reminds me of who i can't put my finger
on
but she weirdly reminds me of the older
sister from the show privileged
do you remember that show yeah the khloe
kardashian look alike yeah she reminds
me of her
and she also reminds me a little bit of
bridget everett
no no i don't see the second one okay
i'm still working i haven't gotten my
the one that like is it but i'm working
those are two that are floating around
there's one that's it and i just
it's bothering me i can't identify it
but it will get there her life seems
extremely interesting
fabulous fabulous and i'm here for the
casting and then when she grabbed that
kid at the party and she was like this
part is kind of making me want to have
kids
you'll be mine for the day and like grab
some random kid it was so funny yeah and
she's like funny and like she'll
do good tv and like hopefully they take
um
a trip on here they need to take a trip
they need to like sync up because
also the show has just like moved to
newport beach like we're no longer in
orange county and that's why when they
drove
to emily's house the kids in bronwyn's
car were like
where are we we're in the middle of
nowhere yeah oh also
when bronwyn picked up shannon for the
night out and shannon opens the door
she's like we're taking a van
oh bronwyn you're driving it was so
funny then pulling up to the bar in a
minivan
yeah hilarious um so honestly i'm
like i said cautiously optimistic it
really isn't as bad as i thought it was
going to be no but something about the
energy is just extremely hectic
yes and i also feel like it's like a due
to them moving to newport beach and like
everything is just like close together
together like i feel like
tight tight yeah no kodo no more no
interesting oh and we were talking last
week where's kelly living she's moving
near shannon and she's still in that
tiny apartment she's in the toasty
apartment
yeah it's very toasty she has this
wallpaper and these couches
yeah um okay so that's our real
housewives of orange county recap and
that's our show anything you want to say
before i wrap it up today
no that's all she wrote so excited for
tomorrow friday last day of the week
can't wait to celebrate with you all
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toastman morning show where
we deliver the past five stories that
you need to know every monday through
friday on youtube so you're watching us
on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcasts
can be found so that's spotify itunes
stitcher public radio i heart radio cast
box we are now available on amazon music
wherever you listen to your podcast find
us the morning toast and leave a
five-star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are
have an amazing day we'll see you
tomorrow goodbye
you